Tôi chung ơn cho đến thơ viện phương, cho đến các kế viện chương.
Khiến tục liên tục, có như thích xa lột thảo loại bình thống chuyện ở đây đào để chúng ta.
Tiến công vào một cái lĩnh vực mới mà giấu tìm năng như như là văn giận nữa rất là khó.
Thế bà mình cũng như là AdTT cũng là một trong những tích sự mẹ học đầu tiên.
Mà đã thiết lập buồn kế khương sẽ hợp tác với cả quốc tế,
đối đại loang với nhặt với anh như thế này.
Để ngay lập tức, anh với anh độ, đặc biệt độ, đến đưa những tích chương trình đào tạo giản giật.
Cũng như thế nước, có lĩnh qua, để bình anh mấy rận vào trong những tích chương trình đào tạo.
Bộ các bạn xin viên mà đang là những cái này kư bà khóp công nghệ,
các thứ mà đang là hợp của ta Ebertay.
Để mình nghĩ là cái tính liên ngoại như vậy là tế liệu rất là tốt để nó có thể chợp lực được đất này.
Yết địa đại phản cấp thiết của nền tính tế,
còn đơn nhiên chúng ta cũng sẽ phải tính đến với chân trình đào tạo,
mà tính bà và hình.
Trình xuất hơn, nhưng mà kế đào tạo mà thất kiểu đã tạo này và luôn để có lực lượng.
Hôm không chờ, để bố năm năm sau chúng ta bị có người để làm,
bởi vì những môi yên hòa tiền như thế này là rất cẩn thiết.
Tên như mà người có lại đi.
Trước đây, đôi khi là trong độc bối cảnh không phải là năm bà.
Đôi thì cũng rất là khó để phân biệt được,
bởi vì đào tạo linh hòa, có mấy róa, đúng không?
Chứ nên mình cũng nghĩ là, có chuyện của tính thật năm bà,
khi mà có chuyện là uống hộ, như đại độc, hả?
Bình, khoảng 4,5% ở trên đột số.
Thì là cho không ra, cho những tên trương trình và môi hình đào tạo linh hòa này,
bởi vì đúng không?
Bởi vì đúng không?